[Music]
uh you you guys as the three stooges
went uh on the wwe is this right yes now
this was intense because oh they watched
the www yeah yeah that's the crap
that's the other eyebrow show yeah
um you're like we don't watch jersey
shore but wwe
yeah it's a lot of fun you know of
course the last place on earth you've
ever seen me is at the wwe
but uh but we were dressed as the three
students and we walked out there and we
immediately got
booed
but that's what they do that they boo
anybody who's not like a big brother
but so that was kind of it's like the
tradition yeah it was like a wave of
like high school happening to me again
just seventy thousand people booing see
what i got i stopped deprecating so um
but but
the the amount of confidence that these
like 350 pound men have just with the
speedo and paint like it's like it's
confidence i'll never i can't even look
at myself getting out of the shower you
know what i mean and these guys are just
like hey what's up and they just punch
in
walk by playa and it's just boobs and
muscles and just it's craziness there's
women too there's women yeah well that's
why i said boobs but um
but no but the the girl on girl
wrestling is hilarious i mean literally
the girl's ass is in another girl's face
like oh bro i'm getting pinned oh no
you know and
it's like seven-year-old boys are
watching with their dads who are like
this and the seven girls
wow quality television and yet it's
brought my audience together